thank you
[Music]
I'm Richard Jefferson and I'm joined
with what's your name uh JR Smith the
J.R Smith and this is truth or dare
hey what's going on everybody I'm Sean
Evans and welcome back to another
exciting episode of Truth or dab
presented by Google pixel it's the show
where we give our guests two simple
options tell the truth or suffer the
Wrath of the last app and with
basketball season hitting this Crescendo
I'm very excited to welcome two legends
in the game Richard Jefferson and J.R
Smith religions Legends of the game
speak for yourself
Richard Jefferson a 17-year vet who won
a title in 2016 and who now Graces your
TV as an ESPN analyst and J.R Smith a
15-year vet who's adding Collegiate
golfer and soon to be college graduate
to a resume that already includes a pair
of rings fellas welcome to the show
alright so let me explain what's going
on here before we get started now in
front of you you guys have a plate of
wings that have all been doused in
various versions of the last app I have
a set of deeply personal potentially
awkward questions for each of you and
when I ask you a question you have a
choice answer it honestly or escape the
truth by eating a Deathwing and Richard
yes we're going to start with you okay
you know over the course of your 17-year
MBA career you played with eight
different teams and your vast experience
which NBA franchises front office
executives are most out of their depth
oh what like the ones that I played with
yeah I'm gonna say uh the New Jersey
Nets and Rod Thorne just based off of
trading me and then the team went to
crap afterwards straight truth straight
truth Richard
Jefferson's face
all right Jr turning to you during the
2011 NBA lockout you signed with the
Chinese basketball association's golden
Bulls where you average more than 30
points per game and once scored 60 off
the bench set the record straight is it
true that you never attended to practice
and if so would you do with your time
that is not true I actually I did attend
practice for the first two weeks they
then told me you don't have to come to
practice so so you all right I was like
okay he's like listen if you scored 30
again you don't have to you don't have
to come to practice honestly true true
professional and you know what I think
that makes sense it's a results driven
League you know if you're scoring 30 why
waste your time with practice moving on
to Wing number two Richard we're gonna
stay with you okay college basketball
fans they have to remember the dominance
that you had the University of Arizona
where your teams never lost more than
eight games in the season you played for
a national title but to avoid eating a
Deathwing I'm gonna need you to say
something genuine and nice about Duke
Energy
there we go
diving on in what gonna happen it wasn't
gonna happen hmm oh is it oh yeah it's
Richard when you came in you said you
weren't sure if you were a spicy food
guy naturally like a spicy food guy or
we're gonna find out how's it feeling
right now you look pretty good actually
I'm gonna be really honest like I would
choose death before saying something
about positive so Wing this is I'm I'm
gonna say
my ball head's starting to sweat it's
fine what are you
is someone who has once fined fifty
thousand dollars for trying to untie an
opponent's shoelaces at the free throw
line I'm curious looking back on your
career
that's a car
in the rear what would you say was the
finer suspension that was most unfair
probably it might be it might be the
shoelace because
to me it wasn't fifty thousand dollars
worth of shoes
punishment didn't fit the crime yeah it
just didn't fit the crime for me prior
history yeah it was definitely there's
so many priors that I had it was just
like you know what that was the soup
hahaha
what's the soup
no but the question was to you so 2017
I'm gonna
cafeteria you know we're
getting great soup by the way it just so
happened it was my favorite it was
uh you're right I am a much better
storytellers
I don't I'll help him out basically what
happened is that we're all in the food
room I was not there I've heard this
second hand but there was one certain
coach that was chirping to Jr about
something and Jr decided to it wasn't
chirping he kept touching me and I told
him and I threw my suitcase yeah so it
was a bowl of hot soup on a Coke a hot
soup hot wings and we're moving on here
to round number three so for round
number three I'm gonna ask you to use
the Google pixel folds that are on the
tables in front of you we have some
pictures that we're gonna bounce off of
you guys to get a little bit of a
reaction
my hands are slippery from the wings I
know so Richard we'll start with you so
there might be some younger basketball
fans who see you on TV as an ESPN
analyst they forget about the dazzling
dunk highlights that you had nightly
explain why this dunk over Klay Thompson
is on your Mount Rushmore but I also
need a dunk that you're on the receiving
end of that you'd like wiped from the
Internet history forever the reason why
this dunk is on the Mount Rushmore is
because
that was probably the greatest Christmas
Day game of all time it was the first
time that we were the defending
Champions and the Warriors had added
Kevin Durant so that was the first time
that everyone got to see that match up
for me what makes it better is that I
was on the Warriors with when they
drafted clay so the dunk on your boy and
there's nothing greater than that and
one that I would like wipe from the
books probably at Mary's thought admire
he punched me pretty bad that was a a
bad moment for me that everyone on the
internet likes to bring up very very
consistently at all times
that's what I say I'm like dude he's
like he's he's bigger than me it's like
he's like
so that one I would like white
all right Jr now on to you look at that
beautiful swing do you see that golf
swing right there imagine that's what
you're looking at and as The Story Goes
you caught the golf itch when Moses
Malone invited you to a charity
tournament and today you hold your own
against some of the nation's top golfers
but I am curious who is the celebrity or
athlete that is the worst golfer you've
ever shot around with I would have to
say Anthony Anderson
That's my boy yeah it was a long day
just duffing we had a day
he's a great guy I love him sweetheart
but man can't golf this golf game I need
some work last but not least there's a
couple pictures of you guys together oh
oh look at my guy look at that there you
go just Classics both of you and I'm not
sure if you're aware of this but you
know that as teammates you guys had a
winning percentage of 670. that seems
that clock's about right that clock's
about right seems like we were doing our
job well at a high level at a very high
level so what I'd like you to do here
now that you guys have played so much
ball together is to look at each other
and tell the other their best and worst
quality as a teammate okay that's easy
okay yeah okay your best quality is uh
your honesty your best quality is
definitely your honesty
worst
the first thing about you
you have to completely clear when you
say oh you think I will throw this soup
with you okay I can't be serious
your worst quality as a teammate because
I can never take you serious and nobody
can't
you play way too much
I think I've seen you be serious twice
it's quality or you just want to leave
it there no the best quality is his
honesty I will give him that he's out
he's he's 100 honest
whether you like it or not well speaking
of 100 honest we're on to here the final
round and Truth has been riding you
through this whole thing Jr you are on
to this Final Round We are some truthful
people Richard congrats on passing the
four-year Mark at ESPN thank you how
much money do you make yearly
oh
you might want to take that bite my way
let me say this and I say this with all
due respect one reason why I'll say this
is because my my contract is up in a
couple of months
not enough
[Laughter]
going and going in in Jr to close things
out honest answer if you guys both
texted LeBron for a favor at the same
time who would he get back to First
it goes Richard Jefferson J.R Smith a
game of Truth or dab living to tell the
tale
anything that you want to say to the
viewers at home before we put you into
an ice bath
it's higher than it looks [__] sure
why did I take that Big Bite why did you
take such a big why'd you wait till the
end to start this I didn't I didn't want
to tell you that he was gonna hit you
back first
[Applause]
I got whole milk too did they suspend
you for the super did they find it
a game is paycheck boom